[Music]
hello dear friends and thank you for
joining us here on your program I'd like
to know we're delighted to be here with
you to share from the word of God the
answers to the questions that you
send US Weekly and we are delighted to
be able to share from the word and with
wonderful friends that study the
scriptures that understand the Bible
these answers that we pray will be a
blessing to you and your family I want
to present to my right Pastor Stan bour
thank you for being with us Pastor we're
a delight to have you here it's a
pleasure to be here on this my favorite
program Amen to that and to my right
Pastor Miranda welcome once again Pastor
we'd love to have you here in our
program thank you it's good to be back
again in this program that I really like
um the Highlight to know amen we have
the opportunity to interact with people
and read their questions and this
actually helps us go deeper into the
Bible absolutely pastor and really is
our favorite program here on S TV and we
want to invite you to send your
questions to the following address tvsm
tv.org I want to see you write us
questions and have patience with us as
we have to take a little time to
research and answer them but we promise
you that we'll answer the questions as
we get them now before we start we want
to ask the Lord to lead us into all
truth through the holy spirit so I'm
going to invite Pastor Miranda to pray
for us in this moment okay let us pray
Heavenly Father which are in heaven we
are so thankful for the opportunity of
being once again in this wonderful
program thank you for the questions we
have received which tell us that there's
people out there studying the Bible
searching the scriptures and wanting to
know what is the way of Truth and we
pray that as we lead out in this program
that you may give us the wisdom and
understanding to answer these questions
correctly in the name of Jesus we pray
amen amen amen thank you so we'll start
with our first question and this is a
question that comes from a friend and is
uh his name is Henry and it says the
following I am told by a former
Adventist that the fourth Commandment
does not not have to be kept because he
considers it a ceremonial or part of the
ceremonial law therefore he does not
believe that the fourth Commandment is a
requirement how would you respond to
such a ridiculous statement I think this
is a very interesting question and I
think the answer uh somewhat comes to to
us in in answering this question like
it's a ridiculous statement but we have
to answer nevertheless we have to answer
these people from the word of God what
will you Pastor Pastor Bor Pastor
Miranda can share about this question in
regards to
Sabbath well I think you have to be
blind not to see in the Bible the
difference between the ceremonial
Sabbath and the Sabbath of the Ten
Commandments there are clear differences
in the Bible in regards to both number
one we find that the Sabbath was
established not during the time of Moses
m it was established at creation even
before the entrance of sin yes where no
ceremonies were required no types that
pointed to a sacrificial sacrificial
lamb to a redeemer were given because uh
there was a perfect world and the
Sabbath was given as a sign of creation
now it is true that the Bible does
mention about ceremonial sabbaths we see
these in Leviticus 23 there were
actually seven in total in the year uh
these were
holidays that were
kept by in the time of the Jewish
festivals and they not necessarily
needed to be the seventh day it could be
any other day of the week but the
seventh day Sabbath was established by
God at creation is the last day of the
week and it was supposed to be kept by
his people uh another thing is that in
the Bible when it refers to the Sabbath
of the Lord is always in singular mhm
while it refers to the ceremonial
sabbaths usually is in plural for
example in Colossians chapter 2 we find
here a reference to those ceremonial
sabbaths and we read here the
following C Colossians chapter 2 uh
beginning in verse 13 uh actually 14
having wiped out the handwriting of
requirements that was against us which
was contrary to us and he has taken it
out of the way having nailed it to the
Cross having disarmed principalities and
Powers he made a public spectacle of
them triumphing over them in it so let
no one judge you in food or in drink or
regarding a festival or a new moon or
sabbaths in plural which are a shadow of
things to come but the substance is of
Christ so notice here that the Sabbath
are mentioned also in relation to foods
and drinks and new moons which are
things that were related to those feast
days so this is not the Sabbath of the
Lord this is these are the ceremonial
Sabbath so yes those were nailed to the
cross but not the Sabbath that is part
of the law of God James 2:10 says that
if we keep the whole love but we
transgress in one point we're guilty of
all amen bastor bour when the Sabbath
was established in Genesis mhm there was
no Jew
mhm there was no old Covenant mhm there
was no ceremonial
law it's part of God's original plan
absolutely because it was created before
sin now when you
compare the story in Genesis with the
fourth
Commandment you know that it's the same
Sabbath for two
reasons in Genesis it tells us that the
Sab Sabbath is the seventh day and God
did three things he rested he blessed
and he
Sanctified in the fourth Commandment it
says that the Sabbath is the seventh day
and it says that God rested God blessed
and Sanctified it's the same Sabbath yes
so the Sabbath predates the ceremonial
law because the first ceremonial law
that we find record of in the Bible is
when a Abel offered an animal Sacrifice
from his flax that's the first explicit
we know that Adam made an offering
according to the spirit of Prophecy but
the first biblically recorded uh
instance of a ceremonial law is the
killing of the Lamb which symbolized the
coming Messiah now uh Pastor Miranda
mentioned this uh the feasts mhm from
Leviticus chapter 23 correct those
pointed forward to functions of Christ
that that he would fulfill when he came
to this earth mhm Passover represents
his death correct un liven bread his
burial uh first fruits his
resurrection Pentecost his installation
as high priest in the Heavenly Sanctuary
after his
Ascension um in
1844 the trumpets the announcing of the
soon coming day of atonement and then of
course you have the day of atonement
October 20-8 1844 it begins mhm so so
all of those feasts pointed forward to a
greater reality the Sabbath was not a
shadow to point forward MH the Sabbath
is part of God's original plan amen and
we have to remember like uh just to you
know add to what you both have
established Sabbath will be a Eternal
aspect is Isaiah 6622 and 23 mentions us
that when the Lord creates a new Heaven
and new earth from week to week from
month to month from Sabbath to Sabbath
we will come before the Lord so the
Sabbath is not something that is
ceremonial that's not did not Point as
you mentioned to any aspect of the
ministry of Christ is actually something
that was made for men as God said the
Sabbath is made for men and he is the
lord of the Sabbath as well so clearly
the Sabbath is not a ceremonial aspect
at all
furthermore the Sabbath is part of the
10 commandments mhm Christians would
never argue that it's you know uh
adultery was part of the ceremonial law
yeah stealing is part of the ceremonial
law right bearing false witness is part
of the ceremonial law bowing before
Idols is part of the ceremonial law they
would never argue that any of those
Commandments were part of the ceremonial
law that passed away but when it comes
to the Sabbath the devil wants us to get
rid of the Sabbath right and so because
it's part of the Ten Commandments uh the
devil says how can I convince people
that uh you know they don't have to keep
it they say well
uh the Sabbath was uh one ceremonial
commandment in the midst of the Ten
Commandments it's either all of The
Commandments or none of the Commandments
it's that simple I mean it doesn't take
a rocket scientist an Albert Einstein or
a King Solomon to understand that right
the Bible is clear crystal clear on this
particular Point amen and the Lord says
my Sabbath so I believe that we have to
keep that in mind but thank you for the
answer Gentlemen let's go go to the next
question we have from uh another friend
and this one uh I believe is actually
Henry sent another question in regards
to this other experience he has uh he
says I am told by some Adventists that
we're not required to be perfect in this
lifetime in other words totally free of
sin Mrs White States clearly that this
is not correct can you point me to some
scripture that states the same thing
that Mrs G States in her writings so I
suppose the question
is not being not required to have
Victory or we have freedom of sin so
let's see what the Bible says in regard
to
that well this is a very complex issue
when we talk about perfection and sin
actually is simple but theologians have
made it
complex because it is true that the word
perfect or per Perfection mhm can be
used with different connotations and a
different sense yes so for example there
quotes where Ellen y says that no one
should ever say I'm perfect other quotes
where she says that um we can be perfect
in Christ so what kind of perfection is
is len y talking about um it is clear
that Len y opposed any forms of
perfectionism which was a belief back in
those days that uh later it was called
holy flesh that when you receive Christ
he not only sanctifies your mind but he
also sanctifies your flesh that means
that that from then on you're perfect in
the literal sense of the word you are
not going to sin because even the
desires of your flesh are already
Sanctified and it is safe to follow them
she opposed to this kind of
perfectionism now both the Bible and the
spirit of Prophecy are very clear and
and the book of Hebrews in a special way
U talks a lot about perfection the word
Perfection is repeated there several
times and basically a a good definition
in light of the book of Hebrews is
maturity for example I can give you an
ex here a reference from Hebrews let's
go to the book of Hebrews I think it's
chapter
6 let us move on to Perfection
exactly um so here Hebrews
um chapter
6 and actually if we begin from chapter
5 we have the context of what he's
talking about here uh verse 12 for
though by this time you ought to be
teachers you need someone to teach you
again the first principles of the
Oracles of God and you have come to need
milk and not solid food so here there is
a problem with this audience they were
supposed to know better they were
supposed to grow and be more mature but
it seems that they need to go back to
milk and not solid food because there
was no growth in them verse 13 for
everyone who partakes of only of milk is
UN skill in the word of righteousness
for he's a Bape but solid food belongs
to those who are full of age that is
those who by reason of use of their
senses having exercise to discern both
good and evil so there is a contrast
between a mature person and a baby the
mature person can endure solid food the
baby only milk then verse 6 chapter 6
verse one therefore leaving the
discussion of the elementary principles
of Christ contextually this is the
milk let us go onto Perfection not
laying again the foundation of
repentance from the dead works and of
Faith toward god of the doctrine of
baptisms of laying on of hands the
resurrection of the Dead out of the
Eternal judgment so for Paul these
doctrines are milk he said this is good
but let's move on unto Perfection this
we will do if God permits so Perfection
here is character uh
maturity now the brother says in other
words totally free from sin
so if if we define perfection as being
totally free from sin we got to we got
to make sure that we're talking about in
a moral sense character Perfection uh we
do not believe in holy flesh but we do
believe that by the grace of Christ we
can overcome sin if it is in that sense
then this is the Biblical teaching of
perfection so this is in summary what I
could contribute amen and the Bible is
clear as well as the spirit of
Prophecy that um the final
generation will be totally Victorious
over sin which is transgression of the
law right and uh the evidence for that
is is very simple you have to understand
it in the context of the sanctuary right
uh particularly the day of atonement
you know on the day of atonement all of
the
sins that had been truly repented of and
confessed and overcome MH were taken
from the
sanctuary and they were placed on the
head of the
scapegoat and in that way the sanctuary
was
cleansed that's the that's the
um the um ceremony that involves the
scapegoat absolutely okay so in other
words at that point the sanctuary is
totally cleansed right totally cleansed
of all of the sins of those who truly
camea Jes claim Jesus Christ as Savior
so and so when probation
closes the bottom line is that the
sanctuary has been cleansed absolutely
but then Jesus goes back into the
sanctuary and he
changes his Priestly garments to his
garments as king mhm or uh what Ellen
White calls his garments of
Vengeance so uh when probation closes
there's still going to be a period which
is the time of
trouble and after the time of trouble is
the second coming yes now here's the key
point if Jesus has changed his garments
from Priestly garments to garments of a
king he's no longer the
mediator Ellen White clearly says
there's no mediator when closes
absolutely Jesus will be here to protect
us but he will not be here to mediate
for sin so during this period are God's
people going to be able to defile the
sanctuary again they can't no there's no
priest to cleanse the sanctuary no and
so the doctrine of the sanctuary clearly
shows that victory over sin will be
gained before the second coming of
Christ amen and people who say that uh
you know it's not not possible to gain
the victory over sin before Jesus comes
they're not really saying that the
sinful nature is powerful they're saying
that God is weak right because because
the Bible says I can do all things
through Christ who strengthens me so uh
you know some people think that their
sinful nature is more powerful than the
power of God to give us the victory over
sin so they're not saying man is weak
they're saying God is Not Strong yes and
you know the the you as you mentioned
the concept is for us to learn to today
well it's yet a chance for us to learn
to abide in Christ in a regular daily
personal way that way in you know first
John and I invite our friend to to maybe
read some of these these verses in first
John uh that really talk about about you
know overcoming sin Victory but it says
in 1 John chapter 3: 3-5 I I'll I'll
actually through six and I'll read that
just to to kind of clarify the statement
it says and every man that had this hope
in him that hope in Christ purified
himself even as he is pure whosoever
committed sin transgressed also the law
for sin is the transgression of the law
and ye know that he was manifested to
take away our sins and in him is no sin
whosoever abided in him sinth not
whosoever Seth had not seen him neither
known him so so it's really telling us
that the way biblically you can overcome
sin you can have that Victory the the
key is to abide in Christ to really
dwell in his presence to dwell with him
so that when the close of prion comes
when he finish his role those who have
abided in Christ have made that you know
that habit of Habitual being in the
presence of God can then therefore be
free from that sinning experience
because they have put themselves in
harmony with Christ and they're
Sanctified just and in the Bible yeah
the people and also the spirit of
Prophecy the people who are most perfect
M are the ones who feel the least
perfect that's right you know and that's
where Ellen White does say that we can
never say that we're perfect correct but
she's not saying that we can't be
perfect correct what she's saying is we
can never claim to be perfect in fact
those who go through the time of trouble
yeah white says that they're look at
their lives and they can see nothing
good MH but they can't bring any sense
to remembrance that they have not
confessed repented of and forsaken MH so
in other words uh they're going to feel
very unworthy during the time of trouble
and that's what makes them perfect
correct in the sight of God amen amen so
the Perfection we're talking about here
is not absence of sinful nature but is
continual surrender to Jesus Christ
which as Pastor Bor explained there will
be a time when when and those who have
fully surrendered to Jesus will be
sealed with the Seal of the Living God
and they will not sin during the time of
trouble now that doesn't mean and and I
clarify this because I read some of the
arguments in regards to this topic when
we talk about perfection we're not
talking about static thing yeah we're
talking about Dynamic experience because
even after the ceiling Revelation 2211
says that those who are Sanctified will
be sanctified still so there's still
continual growth there are things that
they still need to learn but um but
there is a point where where God will
will s good to seal his people they have
Rich certain experience with God and now
they can go through the time of trouble
uh without a mediator a mediator for sin
not a
mediator uh on behalf of them as Daniel
1 121 says that Michael shall stand up
on behalf of his people so it's not that
they have to go through the time of
trouble on their own strength and
relying on their own merits no they will
still rely on Jesus but not there won't
be a mediator for sin actually just one
more Point real quick I know we're
running out of time but in Philippians
chapter 3 Paul again uses the concept of
perfection and
then verses 12 through 14 and we see
here that Perfection is not a static
experience is a dynamic experience it
says not that I have already received
this or have already been made perfect
the same word in Hebrews ton or teos but
I press on if indeed I may lay hold of
that for which also I was late hold of
by Christ Brothers I do not consider
myself to have laid hold of it or to
have attained it but I do one thing
forgetting the things behind and
staining toward the things ahead I press
on toward the goal for the prize of the
upward call of God in Christ Jesus so
first of all he says I do not claim to
have attained it but then in verse 15
says therefore as many as are perfect
let us hold this opinion so on the one
hand he says I have not attained it yet
but those of us who are perfect let's
continue on so was he perfect or was not
he perfect in the final result he had
not attained it but in his daily
experience he was experiencing
Perfection you know I think that um
those who say that we cannot attain
Perfection of character before the
second coming of
Christ their basic idea is that uh those
of us who teach that it is possible to
gain victory over sin they say well uh
these people are teaching that they're
going to be able to go through the time
of trouble on their own yeah in other
words that uh you know their their
righteousness is going to carry them
through their goodness their Perfection
is going going to carry them through but
Jesus did not say lo I Am With You
Always even unto the cros of probation
yeah he says I'm with you till the end
of the world or to the End of the Age so
Jesus will not be an intercessor in the
sense of contaminating the sanctuary
again during the time of trouble because
it's been cleansed what he is going to
do is that he is going to be Michael as
Daniel 12:1 says he's going to be the
protector of his people because they've
been sealed and they are safe for
eternity amen amen amen this is why we
need to I think finish with this words
that is found in first John again
chapter 1 and verse five says this is
then the message which which have heard
of him and declare unto you that God is
light and in him is no Darkness at all
if we say that we have fellowship with
him and walk in darkness we lie and do
not the truth but if we walk in the
light light as he is in the light we
have Fellowship one with another and the
blood of Jesus Christ his son cleanseth
us from all sin amen that means all sin
and we are cleansed as we walk with him
as we walk in that light that he gives
us so amen I pray that we and our
friends who are watching can all learn
to walk with Christ walk with him be in
a communion in a companionship with the
Lord so we might have Victory and really
experience that beautifulness of
Friendship with the Lord may God bless
you and hope to see you next time here
in our
[Music]
program